- Hello, everyone. In
these next few videos,
I'm going to be talking
about something called,
the Jacobian,
and more specifically,
it's the Jacobian matrix,
or sometimes the associated determinant,
and here, I just want to talk
about some of the background
knowledge that I'm assuming,
because to understand the Jacobian,
you do have to have a little bit
of a background in linear
algebra, and in particular,
I want to make sure that
everyone here understands
how to think about matrices
as transformations of space,
When I say transformations,
here, let me just get
kind of a matrix on here.
I'll call it two one
and negative three one.
You'll see why I'm coloring
it like this in just a moment.
When I say, how to think about this
as a transformation of space,
I mean, you can multiply a matrix
by some kind of two-dimensional vector,
some kind of two-dimensional x y,
and this is going to give us
a new two-dimensional vector.
This is going to bring us
to, let's see in this case,
it'll be,
I'll write kind of two
one negative three one,
where what it gives us
is two x plus negative three times y,
and then, one x plus one times y.
Right? This is a new
two-dimensional vector
somewhere else in space,
and even if you know how to compute it,
there's still room for a
deeper geometric understanding
of what it actually means
to take a vector x y
to the vector two x plus negative three y
and one x plus one y.
There's also still a deeper understanding
in what we mean when we call
this a linear transformation,
a linear transformation.
What I'm going to do is just show you
what this particular
transformation looks like
on the left here, where every single point
on this blue grid, I'm
going to tell the computer,
"Hey, if that point was x
y, I want you to take it
to two x plus negative
three y, one x plus one y.
Here's what it looks like.
Let me just kind of play it out here.
All of the points in space move,
and you end up in some final state here.
There are a couple
important things to note.
First of all, all of the grid lines
remain parallel and evenly spaced,
and they're still lines.
They didn't get curved in some way,
and that's very, very special.
That is the geometric
way that you can think
about this term, this idea
of a linear transformation.
I kind of like to think about
it that lines stay lines,
and in particular the grid lines here,
the ones that started off
as kind of vertical and horizontal,
they still remain parallel,
and they still remain evenly spaced.
The other thing to notice here is
I have these two vectors highlighted:
the green vector and the red vector.
These are the ones that started off,
if we kind of back things up,
these are the ones that started off
as the basis vectors, right?
Let me kind of make a
little bit more room here.
The green vector is one zero,
one in the x-direction,
zero in the y-direction,
and then that red vertical vector here,
is zero one,
zero one.
If we notice where they land,
under this transformation,
when the matrix is multiplied
by every single vector in space,
the place where the green vector lands,
the one that started off as one zero,
has coordinates two one,
and that corresponds very
directly with the fact
that the first column of
our matrix is two one.
Then, similarly, over
here, the second vector,
the one that started off as zero one,
ends up at the coordinates
negative three one,
and that's what corresponds with the fact
that the next column
is negative three one.
It's actually relatively simple to see
why that's going to be true.
Here, I'll go ahead and
multiply this matrix
that we had that was ...
See now it's kind of easy to remember
what the matrix is, right?
I can just kind of read it off here
as two one negative three one,
but just to see why it's
actually taking the basis vectors
to the columns like this,
when you do the
multiplication by one zero,
notice how it's going to take us to,
so it's two times one, that'll be two,
and then, negative three times zero,
so that'll just be zero,
and over here, it's one times one,
so that's one, and then, one times zero,
so again we're adding zero.
The only terms that actually matter
because of the zero down here,
was everything in that first column.
Similarly, if we take that same matrix,
two one negative three one,
and we multiply it by zero one over here,
by the second basis vector,
what you're going to get,
is two times zero, so zero,
plus that element in that second column,
and then, one times zero, so another zero,
plus one times one, plus that one.
Again, it's kind of like
that zero knocks out
all of the terms in other columns.
Then, like I said, geometrically,
the meaning of a linear transformation
is that grid lines remain
parallel and evenly spaced.
When you start to think
about it a little bit,
if you can know where
the screen vector lands
and where the spread vector lands,
that's going to lock into place
where the entire grid has to go.
Let me show you what I mean
and how this corresponds with,
maybe, a different
definition that you've heard
for what linear transformation means.
If we have some kind of function L,
and it's going to take in a
vector and spit out a vector,
it's said to be linear if
it satisfies the property
that when you take a
constant times a vector,
what it produces is
that same constant times
whatever would have
happened if you applied
that transformation to the
vector, not scaled, right,
so here you're applying
that transformation
to a scaled vector,
and evidently, that's the same
as scaling the
transformation of the vector.
Similarly, second property of linearity
is that if you add two vectors,
it doesn't really matter if you add them
before or after the transformation.
If you take the sum of the vectors
then apply the transformation,
that's the same as first
applying the transformation
to each one separately,
and then adding up the results.
One of the most important consequences
of this formal definition of linearity,
is that it means if you take your function
and apply it to some vector x y,
I can split up that vector
as x times the first basis vector,
x times one zero
plus y,
let's see y, times that
second basis vector,
zero one,
and because of these two
properties of linearity,
if I can split it up like this,
it doesn't matter if I
do the scaling and adding
before the transformation,
or if I do that scaling and adding
after the transformation,
and say that it's x times
whatever the transformed version
of one zero is,
and I'll show you
geometrically what this means
in just a moment, but
I kind of want to get
all the algebra on the screen,
plus y times the transformed version
of zero one,
zero one.
To be concrete, let's actually put in
a value for x and y here,
and try to think about that
specific vector geometrically.
Maybe I'll put in something
like vector two one.
If we look over on the grid,
we're going to be focusing
on the point that's over here
at two one, and this particular point.
I'm going to play the transformation,
and I want you to follow this
point to see where it lands,
and it's going to end up over here.
Okay, so, in terms of the old grid, right,
the original one that we started with,
it's now at the point one three.
This is where we've ended up,
but importantly, I want you
to notice how it's still
two times that green vector
plus one times that red vector.
It's satisfying that
property that it's still
x times whatever the transformed version
of that first basis vector is,
plus y times the transformed version
of that second basis vector.
That's all just a little overview,
and the upshot,
the main thing I want you
to remember from all of this
is when you have some kind of matrix,
you can think of it as a
transformation of space
that keeps grid lines
parallel and evenly spaced.
That's a very special
kind of transformation.
That is a very restrictive
property to have
on a function from 2-D
points to other 2-D points.
The convenient way to encode that,
is that the landing spot
for that first basis vector,
the one that started off
one unit to the right,
is represented with the
first column of the matrix,
and the landing spot for
the second basis vector,
the one that was pointing one unit up,
is encoded with that second column.
If this feels totally unfamiliar,
or you want to learn more about this,
it's something that I've made
other videos on in the past,
but in terms of understanding
the Jacobian matrix,
where we're going with this,
and kind of getting a
geometric feel for it,
that short overview that I gave
should be enough to get us going.
With that, I will see you next video.